it's officially week four of google
cloud next on air which means we're
focusing
on security i'm reto meier and welcome
to this week in cloud where we're taking
a sneak peek
at this week's content week four is
all about security meaning we want to
help you achieve your security goals
while prioritizing operational
simplicity and keeping costs down
so we've got sessions on everything from
data protection to compliance policies
to managing sensitive data
you can also hear directly from other
google cloud customers
sharing their own security experiences
one of the best parts of attending a
conference is learning their clever
and sneaky tips from some of the people
who actually created the products
that's why this advanced im session is
so compelling because
authentication and policy management are
constant
so a deep dive into advanced control
sounds like a great way
to avoid future policy change conflicts
my pick for the week is getting started
with beyondcorp because
i really like it when we can share the
tools that google is actually running on
that's the google cloud origin story
after all and this session
introduces the beyondcorp security model
and how shifting your security
protections from a physical perimeter
like say your office building to
individual accounts and devices
allows your employees to work remotely
without a vpn
which may be particularly useful to you
in this nonsense
of a year finally if you're looking to
hone your skills be sure to check out
the cloud study jam where you can join
other attendees for guided
hands-on labs there are several options
this week including http load balancer
with cloud armor
and user authentication identity aware
proxy
be sure to register for a study jam to
learn from an expert
to add these sessions to your digital
playlist check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us using the hashtag google
cloud next
we'll see you in the cloud